las tropas ucranianas están aumentando
la presión al recuperar territorio en el
este y el sur y obligando a las fuerzas
rusas a retirarse el miércoles el Estado
Mayor ucraniano dijo que había infligido
pérdidas en la dirección de gerson como
resultado de las exitosas acciones de
las fuerzas de defensa en la dirección
de gerson las unidades enemigas
sufrieron pérdidas y están tratando de
evacuar a los heridos y el equipo a los
cruces más cercanos del Río nipro el
Ministerio de defensa ruso dijo que sus
fuerzas mantenían posiciones en gerson y
repelían los ataques en otro lugar en
lugans un funcionario Ucrania no dijo
que varias ciudades habían sido
recapturadas y que se había iniciado un
proceso de desocupación
todos esos soldados rusos entienden que
no pueden evitar la contraofensiva
entienden que están derrotados y por lo
tanto lo único que pueden hacer ahora es
minar todo lo posible todas las
carreteras todos los edificios
[Música]
Son son dos cuatro regiones que han sido
anexionadas por Rusia junto con doniach
y zaporiya en conjunto representan
alrededor del 18% de Ucrania una
superficie del tamaño de Portugal el
miércoles el presidente Vladimir Putin
firmó una ley que finaliza la anexión de
estas zonas mientras las tropas rusas
siguen huyendo el portavoz del
presidente ruso lo comentó con aparente
ironía
No hay ninguna contradicción aquí
estarán con Rusia para siempre serán
reclamados en una de las primeras
muestras de la influencia de Rusia sobre
las regiones anexionadas Putin ordenó al
Estado tomar el control de la central
eléctrica de zaporilla también dijo que
esperaba que la situación se
estabilizaran los territorios
anexionados pero en Rusia aumenta el
escepticismo el miércoles un diputado
ruso de alto nivel que también es el
presidente de la comisión de defensa del
parlamento pidió al Ministerio de
defensa que deje de mentir sobre lo que
está ocurriendo sobre el terreno en
Ucrania